so good morning thank you all for being
here I'm going to talk about cereal it
is today for you and the stock is
intended as sort of like a gentle
introduction into CEO duties so if
you're already familiar with them you
might not see a lot of new things but I
will try to make it to go beyond the
mechanics of realities and really give
you a bit of an intuition about what it
means so the goal of theologies is to
make it easier to write correct
eventually consistent systems so to
achieve consistency in distributed
systems and I'm sure you're all pretty
familiar with with this concept but I'd
like to build it up from the start real
quick so the really simple case is when
we have just one server there were a
couple people writing to that server and
a couple people people reading oh that's
pretty simple right it's pretty clear to
see that this will work so the problem
is just going to be network failures and
all kinds of failures so this means if
the server is in Europe and your users
are in America and connections gone then
these users don't have any can't get any
work done so that's not very good so the
obvious solution is to distribute it so
you distribute the information of
multiple servers people write to the
servers and people read from the servers
if the connection between two of those
servers go sound then the people work
that are connected to that can which one
of them can still get work done so that
sounds great in theory but of course in
practice we still get Network failures
and it's not obvious how to deal with
them so you want it to look like they're
still like this nice consistent
sequential development of values but you
can't really achieve that
easily because you don't have any
consensus between the service so like to
simulate like make it look like the
cluster is just one server it would need
strong consistency and this is basically
impossible when a and B are entirely
disconnected at some time so this is
what people mean when they say you can
when you when there are petitions you
cannot have availability and consistency
at the same time because to get
consistency you would have to have some
kind of communication between the
different servers where you would like
to make progress so the basic thing that
we've done is we introduced eventual
consistency so this is something you
probably all very familiar with so
instead of saying okay we want to make
it look like this is one sequential
development of values it's okay to be
eventually consistent so not to have not
to be directly in the same state but
after the partition has resolved so this
gives you the freedom to make systems
that have very nice properties but it's
also complicated and serious these are
one way to think about algorithms that
are achieving eventual consistency and
the first thing that series do to make
this more simple is we actually raise
the bar a bit so actually instead of
just saying we want eventual consistency
so after the network petitioner has
results you want to be consistent again
we say once a note has seen the same
events that note has to be in once two
notes have seen the same events those
two notes should be immediately in
exactly the same state so that restricts
the
smart things you can do with distributed
algorithms but it also makes them much
more simple because if you achieve this
that makes it easy to think about ok so
let's look at a really simple example of
what a distributed algorithm could look
like and so from here we go to fat we'll
go further we'll explore see where the
limitations are and then we will
discover the rules that serial et put on
us to help us make correct distributed
algorithms
so here's there here there are two users
and you can think of them as individual
users but actually they these could be
clusters and the user on top the like
the value they are both started at zero
and what the goal is here we wanted them
to agree on some number and allowed them
to do operations on that number so now
the top user performs the operation plus
five so immediately immediately the
value he sees is five this value also
propagates to the other user and it also
sees the value five so that's as simple
as it can get and so this line it looks
like like a really direct thing but we
don't really think about this like as a
TCP connection but this is some kind of
propagation of the operation through the
network okay so let's make it a little
bit more interesting let's have Alice
and Bob do an operation at the same time
so Alice does minus four and gets one Bo
plus -3 gets two and those operations
are sent off the network they both apply
them and they both arrive at minus two
so that's great so let's see how far we
can go
so this is called an operation based
counter so series we've got two kinds of
sea realities we've got the operation
based ones and the state based ones and
they can express the same algorithms but
they look different they have a diary
different rules so we'll first look at
the rules for the operation based
cheerleading and so let's see what
happens when we are multiplication to
the mix and we'll see that when we are
multiplication and Alice those times two
Bob those minus one then actually we
don't arrive at the same state so we're
inconsistent so this leads us to the
first rule of operation based Co duties
the operations that can be concurrent so
that can happen at different places in
the network and they'll be crossing each
other they have to commute so plus or
minus commute in the sense that if you
do minus 4 minus 3 or you do minus 3
minus 4 you get the same result
multiplication and subtraction do not
commute in this sense make sense so
let's look at another property and so
I've studied earlier that these lines
these are not like reliable TCP
connections because these are
distributed systems and all kinds of
things can feel so let's look at what
happens when a message is deliver a
scene is delivered twice so LS s plus
five this plus five is delivered at Bob
and then this is delivered again oh then
LS will see five and Bob will see them
so it's obvious to see that this is not
allowed we would get inconsistencies if
we would allow this and this is
basically the second rule for operation
based C realities in an operation based
C or D you have to be able to assume
that your propagation mechanism it
applies to the update exactly once so I
can imagine there's like a couple of
people here who will have alarm bells
going off in their hat right now and
because exactly once delivery is a bit
of a thing and it's the thing because
it's impossible in distributed systems
and this is something that leads to a
lot of confusion
so the reason it's impossible it's
actually quite easy to see because who
acknowledges the acknowledgement when
you want to deliver a message it's
exactly once
well you send it so if you're not
waiting for acknowledgement then you
never know if it's arrived because
messages can drop so if you so say you
wait for an acknowledgement but what if
you don't get an acknowledgement you
don't know if the message got last of
the already acknowledgement got lost and
this is a game you can play all day you
will never win right so luckily so this
means you can have at most once delivery
which is basically send the message hope
it gets processed or you can have at
least once delivery you retry until you
see the acknowledgments and they used up
okay so this sounds disappointing
because how can we ever get will work
done if we can't get exactly what
slavery though the trick is really
simple you can't get exactly once
delivery but you can get exactly once
delivery semantics so if you just make
sure that applying the same update twice
gets you to the same result then there's
no problem and this is what was called
idempotence so rephrasing the operation
based series is rule operation based sea
realities require that your propagation
mechanism make sure that your operations
are sent over in an idempotent way okay
so let's look at yet another data type
this is a little bit more complicated
than just one counter we're going to
look at the sets so let's first look at
a really naive approach at having a
distributed algorithm for sets so Ellis
us x2 the sets Bob also adds X to the
set and these two operations cross each
other but well it's a set so you can't
have the same element twice so nothing
really happens now Ellis removes
acts from the set this gets propagated
to Bob and they all devote see an empty
set so that's okay so far so good but I
call the knife for a reason and say the
message that Bob sending arrived really
slowly it can happen so what do we do
then so all the naive approaches lead to
like surprising results because if we
say if we just are to the set then Alice
will see it but then Bob sees the remove
and they're inconsistent so what do we
do and the tricky thing is you cannot
solve this you cannot solve this in a
way that this is like ideal set so this
means you have to look at your actual
problem and your actual problem is not
getting a set synchronized your actual
problem is something from like you want
to solve some real problem from the real
world and from that real problem in the
real world you can derive which
semantics are actually acceptable to you
so one kind of set in see realities is
the observe to remove sets and what we
do in the absorption move that is when
we add something that two sets before we
really audit to the States we are the
marker a unique marker and then we
remove an element from the set we remove
all the values that match that remove
every instance of the value that we also
send over the marker so basically this
is a set where when operations are when
an out and remove are done concurrently
the are twins so whether you want it or
not that depends on your your business
domain or whatever you want to call it
but it's one way to resolve the
yeah to be conflict-free so the CNC this
is usually called conflict-free and that
doesn't mean that no strange things can
happen at your sources I mean people can
do crazy stuff but you have to build
into your datatype how are you going to
do it deal with it
and this data type well we just defined
that are twins and services don't work
so this leads us to the third and final
rule for for operation based realities
and I'm going to illustrate this by
messages that are have been sent and
arrive in a different order than they
were sent at the source so in our in
this implementation if we altered X a
then we move to X a but at B we see the
addition before we see the removal then
we still get an inconsistent and in case
of state by a sorry in case of operation
based utility we simply say the rule is
that we expect your network we expect
your propagation algorithm to make sure
updates are applied in order and within
order in this case we mean the order
there they've been sent by the source so
it's like when a and B send at the same
time or a sense first and beasts and
second we don't assume that we see those
messages in that order but when a sends
two messages with assume that we see
those two messages in that order so
those are three rules for operation
based abilities and the cool thing is
this is all you need so as long as you
think of a data structure that follows
these three rules you will have an
eventually consistent data type it's not
guaranteed that it's going to do what
you would want it to do
but it's guaranteed that it all the
replicas are going to be in the same
state that yet
so that's a really nice tool to fairly
simple to to think of a really
complicated problem so that's nice but
you're making a lot of assumptions about
our propagation here so we're assuming
exactly one slavery semantics and we're
assuming in order to referee and it
would be nice to lift some of those
assumptions and the cool thing is we can
do that and we can do that with
state-based three duties so state-based
utilities are also data types that will
allow you to design eventually
consistent systems but they work
differently so the operation based
utilities remember you did an operation
you applied it to your local state and
you also sent the operation to the other
nodes in the network with straight by
securities you're doing something
different you do an operation you update
your states and you sent the updated
state of the network and then at the all
the other nodes in the network you will
need to merge the states that are coming
in with your own state and arrive at the
new states so we'll look at another
example and it's again a counter so
Alice does plus five and I've enriched
the state a bit here we're now saying a
has contributed at five to the results
and this makes the value of this data
type five so this is sent over to b and
b now gets the same states so we do a
local object so we changed the empty set
to the set a has contributed five to the
result and we sent it to b and b does
count some kind of merge and where I've
had to say in value so that's good so
let's see how this works for concurrent
operations so again we do a plus four
and A plus three plus four obviously
makes a canal contribute nine to the
result the plus three as a contribution
by B to the result this gets sent over
and we bout to ride for 12 so networks
so let's look at if we actually now are
able to lift some of the new
restrictions we had that operation based
abilities and make less assumptions
about the network so let's look at what
happens with the exactly ones left we
exactly wanted every semantics so if we
assume we allow reasons missions so for
example we allow returns missing the a9
state well as long as your merge
function is idempotent so now the
function is idempotent instead of the
interest infrastructure you're good so
we've basically moved the responsibility
from your infrastructure from your
propagation mechanism to your merge
function okay so the second assumption
we made was in order delivery so say we
have an example where Alice first
contributes five to the result then she
did plus four so see she contributed
nine to the result and those are at
those states are delivered in the wrong
order so what do we do well obviously we
want to arrive at nine so the merge
function function has to be independent
of the order of the states that are
coming in so in other words the merge
function must be commutative and
associative so how do we achieve this in
this in this case but we achieve this in
this case by having our murph merge
function take the maximum contribution
from all the contributions in the state
we cut in so that works but that means
this is an increment only counter
Osterberg me because if you take the
maximum and you lower the value at at a
the merge will ignore that because it
already saw five over five so if you see
I promised you that you can do the same
with state
cuties than what you can do with
operation based unities so how do we get
state based CDT that also can go down so
I have two examples for you four of
state based calendars that solve that so
the first is we can actually combine to
see oddities to get a new CDT so what we
do is instead of keeping track of the
contribution by a to the results we keep
track of two contributions by a to the
result we keep track of the contribution
going up and we keep track of the
contribution going down so here we have
a when we do plus five then we say a
contributes five going up the one we do
minus 4 then we don't say a contributes
one we say a contributes five going up
and four going down and our merge
function takes the maximum of the
component that's going up and I guess
the minimum you should say about the
component that's going down and this way
we can reach eventual consistency so
that's one way to do it
another way to do it is to use version
factors and with version factors we say
well a always knows in which order a is
doing your plate so what I can do is for
the component that a is contributing to
the results it can version that
component so we see a is five in the
second state and then 8 is minus 4 then
we update a state to say a prime is now
1 and if we want to move to merge the a
a is five state with a prime is one
state but we know a prime must be newer
so we know the result should be one so
this is another way to G achieve
if eventual consistency with state-based
realities so let's see what these two
solutions have in common to arrive at
the second and fourth rule for
state-based unities we see they both
have a concept of going forward in the
States so the with the positive negative
counters the values only got larger so
it's easy to see what goes forward with
the versions well the number of primes
get larger so that's notion of going
forward that's in there and as long as
the both the update function and the
merge from C function go forwards along
that axis we're fine
so concurrent States might not be
comparable so for example here the state
that a has applied +4 and B has applied
plus 3 those are not really comparable
because a is further ahead with the with
a and the other one but a B is further
add in the other so but after merging
the merge function always goes goes
forward
so after merging they are they both
arrive at a higher place in the notion
of going forward so in other words
there's a partial order on the states
and both the updates and the merge
increase the state on this order makes
sense though so to recap we've seen two
kinds of CDs we've seen the operation
based charities which are also called
commutative replicated data types
because the operations are sent over the
network and the operations must be
cumulative before we also seen the
state-based here disease those are also
sometimes called the convergent
replicated data types because the states
are sent over the network
and the merge function makes them
converge so I'd like to give you a
really small demo of how this can look
in practice
and the first example I'd like to show
you is react which is a eventually
consistent data store it's made by Basho
Basu is actually a sponsor for the
conference and they have a boot I'm sure
they love you love it if you stop by and
they have introduced some cereal it is
in their database
so what could that look like so you can
just talk to it with a curl and so I
don't have any value in the strange loop
buckets so let's put something in there
so for example I now out to let's get it
again now it's to perhaps I want to
subtract something I will suggest as a
counter and out it's all use minus three
and as you'll see there's nothing to see
here
I mean it's pretty transparent you just
do operations and it works so the in the
rear example it's fairly transparent to
use a user that this is gone going on
under the hood so you get some of the
advantages because if there's a network
petition then you can make progress in
both petitions of the network but you
don't really have to think about it too
much as a consumer of the API you will
have to think about it for example if
you want to use something like assets
because they react has a concept of
assets but as we've seen like the ideal
set is impossible in C or D T's so he
has to be careful that they're their
choice in better in what winds maps with
the choice that you want to see in your
business application but further from
that is you just use it as a consumer
and that's nice but we can go just a
little bit further to so what we can do
is we can make the clients actually part
of the network so if you have some kind
of application on your mobile phone that
application could be a note in your
eventually consistent system and I have
a really small demo of that also so this
is the to do and VC application that I'm
sure you've seen before
and this was built with swarm which is a
JavaScript library for doing this boat
at client-side and at the server side
and these two are synchronized so if I
add something here
it's a below so these are two clients
who are right now come connected to one
server and this uses C realities to get
the state synchronous so we can add
something we can add something else so
what would happen if I now kill the
server you didn't see that I now killed
the server the cool thing about your
Latisse is that now there's the sort of
a networked petition because these two
browsers these two clients are two nodes
in the network that are now no longer
connected to each other and these two
nodes can still make progress and if
these two nodes will be connected to
some server deaths partitions from
another servers server then all the
clients that are connected to that
server could still see all those updates
but of course they're not consider it's
made in other partitions of the network
now if I start the server part up again
it's going to take a while because those
browser those browsers are now trying to
reconnect in a sort of non not to happy
way with the server yep so now when the
server comes online again the two
clients should be able to transport
their updates to that server and through
the server we should see it showing up
in both lines again and because you use
au you see realities and so you follow
to do those pretty simple rules and you
can always be sure that once all the
updates are seen by all the nodes in the
network they will all be in the same
state
that's
Oh
so concluding I'm sorry concluding see
realities have pretty simple rules and
as long as you follow these rules and
you make sure all the updates are
correctly propagated through the network
then you can always be sure that all the
notes are in the same state and as we've
seen with posters negative counter you
can compose them to make more
complicated structures they cannot no
model every data type so for example the
set is like sort of inherently
impossible to model and so this makes it
worth it to really think about your
problem if you cannot express this as a
CDT then maybe you have some opportunity
somewhere to make an assumption and to
have all the nice things - TTT string
bring you of course in some cases your
business domain really requires you to
have something like a perfect set well
in those guys' cases you are going to
inherently need for example strong
consistency so in those cases you know
you don't you cannot use these and you
have to use other techniques but it's
good to be conscious about that choice
so further material so like I said I've
given you a really gentle introduction I
think this gives you a good grounding to
read further so Mark Shapiro is one of
the researches that has done a lot of
work in this area and there's a couple
of videos especially one that he's done
at remarks of research is from in Rio
himself and they're really they're
really good watch so that's really nice
Christopher Michael John has composed a
reading list of a lot of background
material about sea realities that's
really interesting too and he's actually
giving a talk after lunch in the theatre
so that's warmly recommended it's really
looking forward to that one so that
concludes the talk from micro state
perspective I'm open for questions
so yes yes probably so the approach that
you have two sets one ad71
remove set that's actually a common
implementation and the remove sets are
often called tombstones so that way you
can remember you have removed that
element and I think if you do something
smart with with versions you could
probably find safe places where you
could throw away tombstones but I'm not
sure of if any search algorithms around
but I could imagine that yeah okay so no
more questions then yep
yeah probably not I'm not sure so it's
really a trade-off because if you have
situation where you can like really
short your data in really small charts
then growing the state could be like
manageable and so if you for example
have a situation where it's common for
there to be Network protections so for
example you actually expect there to be
network petitions and people being
disconnected for a while then it could
actually be cheaper to have a
state-based
because you can update the state a lot
of times you just have to send the state
over once if it's usually connected then
it's probably true that the operation
based will be more efficient because you
don't have to communicate whole state
every time but it really depends on the
situation in general what you see is
that people say ok state based it's much
easier to think about and then if you
have something that like the semantics
work like you want them to then you can
try to convert it to an operation based
but I think it really depends on your
situation
so that really depends on what your
state look like so in our example we've
indeed we had for each note in the
system we had like a little bit of state
in the state's that's not necessarily
the only way to keep States so it
depends on the algorithm
see
mm-hmm
I'm not aware of any but there could be
yeah but no if there's no more questions
then thanks very much for your attention
and I hope you enjoy the rest of the
conference